the Joe Rogan experience I think that's
one of the things like you really have
to get into those valleys to appreciate
to really hit those peaks I think that's
what's going on right now as you're
saying that I'm thinking about like
literally what's happening in this
country and I hope that you know we get
to the point where we see the Sun and we
feel it but then we have to also not
forget I think you're a hundred percent
right I think we have it really really
easy in this country what you were
saying about this is the reality of
third world countries or places where I
mean you're under a military
dictatorship where you can't get food
you can't travel wherever you want to
you don't have the freedom to move about
whenever you want to and we're in this
weird situation here today in California
they've put this lockdown on everybody
where supposedly until April 19th you
can't have a gathering of more than 10
people and you're all essential
businesses are supposed to be closed
like well [ __ ] good luck with that
yeah good luck good luck good luck with
a whole month of pee telling people they
can't work this is crazy
I had a experience that stuck with me
that that I use as like a lens of
context from overseas and it was from
Afghanistan I was in a sniper overwatch
position and I was watching a it was on
one side of the valley there was a unit
on the other side of the valley and
there was a village in between and I
watched an individual come out in the
morning to the only water source in the
valley small stream and watch him just
take a [ __ ] in the water oh Jesus Christ
and then later on in the day another
person came out and downstream of that
took a bath in the water and later on in
the day a woman came out with two kids
and got their drinking water downstream
from both of those things and went back
to their house and it's like okay we
have it really really good really really
really really good and in that village
there was probably a light bulb why did
he take a [ __ ] in the river maybe he
didn't have any toilet paper because the
grocery store was out yeah I mean so
that's the thing about people that's
this willingness to do something that
you know is going to negatively impact
others but you don't care because in the
moment it
good for you when you see someone
throwing a cigarette out the window of
their car that's a perfect example that
they don't want that cigarette in their
car so they just say Oh somebody else
will handle it yeah but if you see
enough of those things or in that it
reframes the way that you look at what
people complain about hmm and I've
thought about that day very often
because in that short period of time
it's just like I don't ever really have
that much to complain about like what's
gonna go on right now for the next few
months I would guess maybe the rest the
year is gonna be horrendous and I hope
that everybody makes it out okay on the
other side but the reality is people are
gonna die and it's gonna suck and it's
gonna destroy families and there's the
economic destruction will probably be
worse than the physical destruction from
a death side of the house but we're
still gonna be okay at the end of that
and even as if it gets horrendous here
we are doing so much better than so many
other people on the face of this earth
their daily best is not gonna even
approach what its gonna look like at our
worst as we navigate our way through
this my biggest concern is not just the
deaths which is a big concern not just
the financial crisis which is also a big
concern but it's also the government
gobbling up freedoms in in exchange for
the illusion of safety that's a real
concern it's been happening for a long
time though yeah but it's it's also
whenever there's a real crisis there's
always an excuse to pass legislation
that diminishes our rights I mean it's
just it makes it easier for them makes
it easier for them to do what they
perceive to be their job only if people
are scared yeah it's you know because
they're finding the seams and people's
attention span they're instead of being
objective they're being emotional and
that clouds your vision and in a cloud
your judgment and when they're not
paying attention because they're scared
because they're online all goddamn day
looking at people taking pictures of the
empty toilet paper aisle in the grocery
store other people who might have
malicious intent are moving on that man
and nobody is paying attention to it
yeah that's where a lot of people that
the more what's the best way to say I'm
trying not to use the word [ __ ]
conspiratorial II minded that don't
think very well the first term was
accurate yeah
they think of it in terms of a gigantic
conspiracy and this is all set up now
people take advantage of moments yeah
and that's the difference that's what
really happens where there's moments
where they can pass something like the
Patriot Act or the Patriot Act to they
do it it's not because they've set this
up to pass that no they use it as an
opportunity because they know that
people are scared and they use it as an
opportunity to further diminish our
rights because it makes it easier for
them to control us and that's a that's a
real concern right now it's a real
concern right now and it's something
that people go oh that's the last thing
you should be thinking about no it's one
of the things you should be thinking
about there's many things you should be
thinking about right now besides your
safety and your health and not spreading
a disease and making sure you wash your
hands and stay away from old people and
maintain social distance all that stuff
is important but also recognize what the
[ __ ] these career politicians and these
career lawmakers and these career people
that are in charge of controlling mass
groups of people any laws that help you
any rights that help you it makes their
job more difficult that's something to
be concerned with right now I think fear
is totally natural I think if you don't
experience fear you might trend towards
the sociopathic side of the spectrum but
it's totally natural it should be
expected but you have a choice and how
you receive what is going on and you can
allow the fear to cloud your judgment
and drive your decision-making process
for you can can recognize that the fear
of something you know fear of death
overseas isn't what keeps you alive
objective analytical thought process and
doing the things that need to be done
keep you alive regardless of how scared
you are or fearful you are that's what
keeps you alive it's okay to be scared
but just don't let it just don't let it
take over yeah in control you
[Applause]